ça fait du bien 24 ans keira est une
jeune fille comme les autres
à peu de choses près depuis la naissance
elle est atteinte d'une myopathie
une maladie qui touche tous les muscles
de son corps et réduit ses capacités
motrices à 20%
un syndrome génétique et héréditaire qui
touche aussi son frère aîné avec le
temps elle à apprivoiser sa maladie et
pris beaucoup de recul
pendant toute ma scolarité par exemple
les gens avaient peur de venir vers moi
c'était souvent moi qui ai fait le
premier pas j'ai la chance d'avoir une
personnalité assez assez forte donc je
vais faire les gens j'ai pas peur
d'aller par des gens et a du coup ça
détend ici sera en fête et comme tout le
monde prendre le bus ou à les acheter
une baguette des gestes du quotidien
qu'elle ne peut pas effectuer seul son
premier obstacle c'est la porte de son
immeuble toujours pas automatisés kerra
rêve pourtant d'indépendance et d'un
mi-temps dans l'administration
mais dans sa situation trouver un emploi
relève de l'impossible trouver du
travail s'est clairement impossible
presque quatre fois là je dois presque à
l'est à 300 km de chez moi pour pouvoir
trouver un travail j'ai fait toutes les
démarches possibles et inimaginables
sachant que j'ai un bac + 3 sa maladie
elle en rit mais comprend aussi qu'elle
puisse faire fuir contrairement à
l'homosexualité la religion ou la
politique
pour elle le handicap reste un tabou en
france chaque jour elle se maquille se
coiffer peaufine son look
et ce n'est sûrement pas le regard des
autres qui va changer ça